We can create a new user by
using the adduser command.
This is an administrator feature,
so we'll have to use sudo as well.
Let's go ahead and
create a new user named student.
We'll then be asked to enter
a password for the student.
I just used the word student,
but as you can see,
in these password fields,
you don't see what you're typing.
We're then asked the number of
additional questions about the user.
All of these are optional,
so you can ignore them.
But I'm going to go ahead, and
add a bit more additional information
here in the Full Name section.
And that's all there is to it.
We can confirm this user was created
by using the finger command.